Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof. Hello Martin. How are
your team today?
Well, I'm doing good in certain sub
areas and certain not so good. So, let's
just leave it at that. I don't think we
want to get into a discussion of that
because we have more important things to
discuss. Yeah. If we go back and we just
look at the backdrop of the previous
WhatsApp prof, um, we've got the similar
facial expression and feel that that guy
had that poor guy who was contemplating
the circumstances of the church. Yes.
Okay. All right. I thought he was a cat
that was going to disturb the pigeons.
Well, that's why we've got a little
mushroom cloud here on this one. It gets
worse.
Let's open with a word of God. I think
we need that.
Our heavenly father, thank you for
bringing us together again. Please like
always enlighten our minds. Help us
through this this discussion and uh be
with us in Jesus name. Amen. Amen.
Martin, there are a lot of rumors
and nobody really knows what reality is.
And we're talking now about the Middle
East, of course, right?
And what's happening in Iran and what's
happening in Israel, what's happening in
Gaza
and uh the nuclear possibilities
and the nuclear sites that had to be
eliminated.
So there's been a lot of excitement in
the Middle East and as a consequence
of course the various ministries are
debating
as to what the relevance of all of this
is in terms of prophecy.
And we have ministries that claim that
the king of the north is Islam
and that uh particularly pertains to
Turkey.
That was essential part of the Ottoman
Empire.
And now with the situation in Iran and
Israel in between uh is Turkey going to
become involved? Is this going to
fulfill prophecy? Will this king of the
north attack Jerusalem?
And then you have others that claim, no,
the king of the south is Islam and the
king of the north is probably the papacy
and the king of the north and the king
of the south are in conflict with each
other. And somehow Jerusalem is in the
fray and this is fulfilling prophecy.
And Martin, the confusion is so great
out there. And uh then you have the
strikes that you had on the Iranian
nuclear sites
and uh you know the B2 bombers and the
the stealth bombers and the this bombers
and how many of those mega bombs were
dropped and some of them say six and
some of them say 14
and some of them say the the places were
obliterated and others say they were not
obliterated and the Ayatollah himself
said it was totally unsuccessful the
obliteration and the head of the
military says it was totally successful
and the Democrats are saying this and
Trump is saying that and the news outlet
says it was fake news and the other one
says Martin it sounds like rumors and
reality are all mixed up right it's
total chaos actually at this stage
question is does it matter? You see the
problem is and I heard some of these
explanations
that this will be a sign to show where
we are to show how close we are or even
that the close of probation has come
with certain signs that will be linked
to this Jerusalem and Iranian or Islam
and all of these things. All right. So
why are we doing this? I think it is
time that we set certain thinking
patterns
in order.
Uh is the is Islam now the king of the
north? Is Islam now the king of the
south? What is he? Well, those
speculations we've spoken about many,
many times and it has been our
consistent claim that the king of the
north is the papacy.
We have not deviated to the left or to
the to the right on this issue. And
personally, I think that it is erroneous
to involve Islam in any of those
speculations
other than being part and parcel of a
religious unity.
But to claim that he is the king of the
south or by himself the king of the
north is in my opinion and I assume in
your opinion totally erroneous and it is
confusing
and it is not related to the prophetic
picture as outlined in the scriptures
nor in the spirit of prophecy. No matter
what these ministries say, they are in
my opinion barking up the wrong tree. I
think the thing is if it was that
important and if it was supposed to be
that clear then the great contra
controversy would have had much more to
say about it. It had nothing to say on
it. Nothing.
So, let us just try and get a little bit
of perspective
and see who's who in the zoo. And it's
not to follow our opinion on it. No,
let's see what scripture has to say. And
what and as we said in the past, James
White rebuked
Uriah Smith when he claimed that Turkey
was the king of the north. And he said
with much Bible study and backing, he
claimed that this was a ridiculous view
and that the king of the north was the
papacy.
And he was of course rebuked by Ellen
White
because of the way in which he did it
publicly rather than going to his
brother and scrubbing his head for him.
But it seems that that confusion has led
to the fact that some people's heads
need to be scrubbed again today
uh in order to just get the perspective
right. Yeah. So, yes, she rebuked James
White not on what he said, but how he
said it. Correct. That's exactly what
the situation was. And of course, this
all sits
in a package
with how is this all going to play out
and uh when will these final events take
place? And the kingdom of God is is
heavily involved because those that
focus on the Middle East are really
confused with futurism. That's what you
there's a mixture. There's a new mixture
that's been brought out now by our own
ranks. Yes. It's like taking the picture
in the great controversy
and the clear outlines that are present
there as to who has to be watched at the
end of the time. the beast out of the
sea and the beast out of the earth.
Those are the two role players. No, we
are now mixing in Islam and we're mixing
in Turkey. We're chucking it all into a
blender and making a soup that is so
impalatable that nobody can even digest
it, let alone eat it. The thing is it's
it's it will fit into some paradigms
because it's so exciting because, you
know, look at all this turmoil in the
Middle East. I'm just scared that you'll
be sitting waiting for that sign while
all the other things is already starting
to happen. And then you say, "Well, what
happened now?" Yeah. And then you can
put aside some of the clear things
that's happening saying, "Oh, but wait,
wait, it can't be yet because we're
waiting for this." All right. So, we'll
have to look what's happening in the
Middle East. But first, let's have a
look at uh what some people believe has
to happen.
And we have here a discussion between
Tucker Carlson and Ted Cruz. And it's
interesting to see how these
administrators in government think about
these issues. So let's have a look at
it.
You suggested it was a strange thing
that I said a minute ago that when I
came into the Senate, I resolved that I
was going to be the leading defender of
Israel. And what you didn't ask is why.
So let me tell you why. I'm going to
tell you why. Okay? And and the reason
is twofold. Number one, as a Christian,
growing up in Sunday school, I was
taught from the Bible, those who bless
Israel will be blessed and those who
curse Israel will be cursed. And from my
perspective, I want to be on the
blessing side of things. Oh, the those
who bless the government of Israel.
Those who bless Israel is what it says.
Doesn't say the government of it says
the nation of Israel. So that's in the
Bible. As a Christian, I believe that.
Where is that? I I can find it to you. I
don't have the the scripture off the tip
of my You pull out the phone and use the
It's in Genesis. But so you're quoting a
a Bible phrase. You don't have context
for it and you don't know where in the
Bible it is. But that's like your
theology. I'm confused. What does that
even mean, Tucker? I'm a Christian. I
want to know what you're talking about.
Okay. Where does where does my support
for Israel come from? Number one,
because biblically we are commanded to
support Israel. But number two, did I
not? Hold on. You're a senator and now
you're throwing out theology and I am a
Christian and I am allowed to weigh in
on this. We are commanded as Christians
to support the government of Israel. We
are commanded to support Israel and
we're told those who bless Israel will
be blessed. But what? Hold on. Define
Israel. This is important. Are you
kidding? I This This is a majority
Christian country. Define Israel. Could
Do you not know what Israel is? That
would be the country you've asked like
49 questions about. So that's what
Genesis ref that's what God is talking
about. The nation of Israel. Yes. The
And he's So does that the current
borders, the current leadership? He's
talking about the political entity
called Israel. He He's talking about the
nation of Israel. Yeah. Nations exists
and he's discussing a nation. A nation
was the people of Israel. Is the nation
referring to in Genesis? Is that the
same as the country run by Benjamin
Netanyahu right now? Yes. Yes, it is.
I'm talking about the political entity
of modern Israel. Yes. And that is You
believe that's what God was talking
about in Genesis? I do. But but that
country's existed since when? Uh for
thousands of years. Now, there was a
time when it didn't exist and then was
recreated just over 70 years ago. But
I'm saying I think most people
understand
that line in Genesis to refer to the
Jewish people, God's chosen people.
That's not what it says. I don't know
what you're So, you're saying as a
Christian, if I believe in Jesus, I have
to support the modern state of Israel.
I'm not saying that you I'm explaining
for me what my vote motivation is.
Well, Martin, if you've ever heard
confusion, that was it, right?
That's true. I think the bottom line of
that discussion is the question that
Tucker asked him. Define Israel. Define
Israel. The nation, the people, or what
is it? Is it the political entity? No,
it's not the political. Is it the
nation? No, it's the nation. But
whatever it is, they're going to support
it. All right? They go to war for it.
They will do anything to support it. Now
the Bible defines modern Israel very
clearly. It says, "If ye be in Christ,
then ye are Abraham's seed and hes
according to the promise."
So in other words, modern Israel is
those that have accepted Jesus Christ as
the Messiah and enter into his kingdom.
That's modern Israel. We'll look at some
texts later and we'll have to define
this kingdom thing. Yes, this kingdom
thing is very confusing.
So what does the Bible say? The Israel
of old was the literal nation and it was
to take the plan of salvation to the
entire world through the ceremonial law.
They had a complete blueprint of the
plan of salvation. They failed. They
kept it for themselves. They wanted to
become the rulers here on earth. and
they wanted to rule over every nation
and set up a physical entity called the
kingdom of God right down here on earth.
Yep. Christ came and destroyed that
little bubble.
So now for 2,000 years that bubble has
been in the air and now there are people
like Ted Cruz who believe that they have
to set up the dominion the kingdom on
earth. So they are dominionists. Mhm.
All right. So
sooner or later this kingdom has to
come. So it didn't come in the time of
the Jews. So now it has to come right
now. But somehow the Jews are involved
etc etc etc. Now didn't Jesus say your
house has been left for you desolate?
Yes. What does that mean? And we've
discussed that hundreds of thousands of
times. If the house is desolate, it has
no more impact on anything
because God has left it as a nation.
Exactly. That it's gone. It's gone. Paul
very clearly states
that those of the Jewish faith have been
grafted out, cut out of the vineyard.
But if they accept Jesus as the Messiah,
they can be grafted back in. Now just a
question there. Does that mean it will
be a nation that has been draft grafted
in? What does it mean to be grafted in?
Who is the the vine? Jesus. Okay. So,
they have to be grafted back into Jesus.
So, it's individuals that accept him.
Correct. Then they become part of the
kingdom of God. Right. Now, so Martin,
the nation of Israel has zero relevance
as far as the Bible is concerned. And
the terminology that you have in the
Bible like the Israel of God, it's those
who wrestled with God and overcame.
That's what the word Israel means,
right? Him that overcame. Yes. No longer
is he the suppler. He is the one who
wrestled with God and overcame. It is a
spiritual kingdom.
The physical kingdom will come, but on
its terms, not on our terms. we'll deal
with that and that kingdom is not of
this world. So the present kingdom or
nation
physical entity political entity that
you have in the Middle East
is nothing other than a masonic
construct
set up in 1948
representing
this nation.
It's not a nation set up by God. It's a
nation set up by a masonic construct
where nations like the Britons and the
United States and the United Nations and
all of them together set this up. Now
there must be a reason for this because
there must be a plan behind it
somewhere. But as a nation they have no
role to play in the final events of
prophecy. So that's a political thing
and there's a biblical thing also linked
to this. The biblical thing is is
desolate. Correct? So God's people's
eyes must be on the king of the north.
And of course, if you're going to define
the king of the north as a political
entity sitting in the Middle East, then
you're going to make the type the same
as the antitype. you will be totally
lost in the sea which is a universal
conflict of ideologies.
It centers in Christ.
And if Israel and Islam have a war with
each other, both of them deny Christ.
Yeah.
It's irrelevant in terms of the final
construct. The center, the cornerstone
that was rejected is Jesus. And it is
Jesus and his kingdom that is at stake,
not kingdoms that have rejected him.
So we'll come back to that. So now these
people that want to set up this
construct of a kingdom here on earth on
behalf of Jesus Christ so that he can
come and take it when the time is right.
let's say after a thousand years or
whatever it was. Hitler also thought he
was going to set up a a thousand year
Reich. It never materialized. The Jews
thought they were going to set it up. It
never materialized. But this hope
eternal remains in the human mind.
Right? It's like the toes the king the
10 toes of the Daniel statue. Europe is
trying to unite to put up a government
on earth. Correct. And this issue is so
confusing. Now the the top theologian
working with this issue and setting up a
kingdom here and and taking control of
the issues and Christian morality is
Douglas Wilson. Right. Now he discusses
he discusses this talk between Cruz and
Tucker Carlson, doesn't he? Yeah. So, so
let's listen to what he has to say to
sum up. Uh I would say that Tucker uh
made some points and Ted Cruz made some
points. They both have something to say.
And Tucker seems to want to say that
that verse in Genesis has nothing to do
with anybody today. Uh which is
problematic. And Ted Cruz appears to
want to say that it is it applies
straight across to the people of Israel
um in the Middle East today. And that's
problematic. It is possible that Tucker
when he says that the Genesis passage is
referring to God's chosen people that he
he thinks he believes that it's
referring to the Jews throughout the Old
Testament and to the Christian church
simply and solely in the time of the
New. I think it does refer to the
Christian church in the time of the New
Testament. But I also believe that
ethnic Israel, ethnic uh Jews are
promised a reinccorporation back into
that church. The Bible taken as a whole
does indicate that there is a role to
play the uh a role to play for the
Jewish people uh yet to come in Israel.
Again, Romans 11. And incidentally, just
apart from dispensationalism,
this has been the historic reformed
position from the time of the
reformation down over and over and over
again um reformed scholars, preachers,
theologians have affirmed the the future
conversion of the Jews, which is a
reformed um distinctive. Now, Martin,
that was very interesting
because here you have a theology
that seems to want to combine Judaism
and Christianity.
Now, we've shown over and over again
that even the members of the modernday
Sanhedrin, if you want to call it that,
claim that their Messiah is not Jesus
Christ. In fact, the Talmud totally
rejects Jesus as the Messiah. And some
of them are very viciferous. They
actually hate the idea that Jesus Christ
should be the Messiah. So, they're
waiting for another one.
Now it is true that many of the Jews
will see the light and accept the gospel
and will be grafted into the vine again
and uh they will accept Jesus as the
Messiah. But as a nation their house is
desolate which means they are forever
forsaken of God. The issue is are you in
Christ or are you not in Christ? Now, so
the focus on saying evangelism reaching
the world, there's no more special p
people on earth that has to be reached.
Now, this sounds like the Jews or the
Israelites will have a special time
where they will be looked and reached as
according to or um compared to the other
ones. And that's not biblical. No, they
are without Christ. No, therefore they
are a target of evangelism.
Islam is without Christ. Therefore, they
Nothing else. Nothing else. Let's repeat
that. Nothing else. If they accept Jesus
as individuals, because I doubt whether
as a nation they will ever do this, then
fine. If not, then they are outside the
covenant because the covenant is linked
to where the Messiah is. And the Messiah
is Jesus Christ. He fulfilled the
biblical prophecy of Daniel 8:9. And
therefore, they have no excuse for
having rejected him. Well, maybe I can
just also we can just tell the viewers
that we did have a discussion recently
that was recorded that we did with some
um two other ministries and we were
having talks with um one of the people
that have a Christian nationalist view.
Yes. So that will be aired on the 17th
of July. Yes. So people can watch out
for that. If possible, if willing, this
Douglas Wilson that we've just shown
will have a similar talk with him with
these other guys. Yes. And of course, we
will have a viewpoint that doesn't
embrace what he believes. So that will
be interesting. And one question that I
would like to ask is he mentioned here
the reformers and the reformed views but
then why don't they acknowledge the
reformed views on maybe the Sabbath and
some of those things and the antichrist
and the antichrist. So we'll get to that
interesting questions but for now so we
have a a very very mixed theology. So
let's just go to the Middle East and see
what is happening there. behind the
scenes other than bombs flying. Yeah,
let's forget about the bombs flying.
Well, here's an article about uh Trump
who says that he, you know, he should
actually qualify for the Nobel Prize. He
said he should have gotten five Nobel
Peace Prizes while continuing to weigh
uh Iran strikes. Presumably aware of
Trump's desire to be seen as a
peacemaker, former Florida Congressman
Matt Gates argued on his One American
News Network show Thursday that he could
see the Nobel Honor renamed to the Trump
Peace Prize if he avoids war. Trump was
asked about this Friday after flying to
New Jersey to spend time at his golf
club. Well, they should give me the
Nobel Prize for Rwanda,
he told reporters. And if you look to
the Congo, or you could say Serbia,
Kosovo, you can say a lot of them. You
could say, I mean, the big one is India
and Pakistan. I should have gotten it
four or five times. I would think the
Abraham Accord would be a good one, too.
M now Martin is is he claiming the
honors for having pushed through the
Abraham Accord? Definitely. Yeah. The
whole time. Martin, who's the Abraham
Accord between? Well, it's between Islam
and Jew Judaism and Christianity. H be
careful there. Be careful there. What
branch of Christianity? Not the biblical
one. Not the biblical one. Would you say
that it is largely Catholic
Christianity? Yeah. And if you look at
the major buildings that have been
constructed, you know, the Jewish
synagogue and the Islamic uh buildings
that have been erected there as well as
the Catholic ones, they are exceedingly
Catholic,
Islamic and Judeaic. Right. Mhm. So the
Abraham Accord that he claims is so
important that it qualifies for a Nobel
Peace Prize. He set it up. They won't
give me a Nobel Pri priest prize because
they only give it to liberals.
Now Martin, the others that he mentioned
there are political wars. Yeah. But this
one is a religious accord. Is that
interesting to you? Very.
Now let's take the Islamic world. Is it
part of the Abraham a cord? Yes. Yes.
Question.
Do all
Muslims sit on the same side of the
fence or are they divided into Shia and
Sunni Muslims? Yes, they're divided
among themselves. Yeah. Ah. What is
Iran? Shia. Shia Muslims.
What is Saudi Arabia? Sunni. Martin. Do
all Islamists sit on the same side of
the fence? No, there's a division.
There's a division between Sunni and
Shia. Okay, just explain to us what is
the difference. Okay, this divide comes
ever since the time of Muhammad. Okay.
The Shia Muslims believe that uh there
has to be a physical heir, okay, in
ruling uh a descendant of Muhammad. But
Muhammad left no clear heir.
So the Sunni Muslims believed that one
of his great supporters like Abu Bak or
one of them they could be also a leader
in in the the Muslim world. So the
Ayatollah has to be a physical heir if
he is a Shia. Now Iran
consists of Shia Muslims. wasn't always
like that by the way. Whereas the rest
of the Arabic world is Sunni. So the
Ottoman Empire were largely Sunni
Muslims. Uh Saudi Arabia is Sunni. All
of those Islamic states that are in the
Abrahamic Accord are Sunni Muslims.
So wouldn't it be nice to have the
Shiats also on board? Yeah. That's
interesting, Martin. Then when you talk
about 911
and Taka had a very interesting
discussion on 911 or whether it was a
real thing or not a real thing etc etc.
So we're not going to go there lest we
open that can of worms. The point of the
issue is who were the ones then that
were supposedly or literally whatever
way you want to think about it causing
the trouble. Wasn't that Saudi Arabia?
Yes, that's Sunni Muslim. That's Sunni.
Yeah. But the pariah, the bad guy in the
game today is Iran. That's Shia. Well,
it's now it just brings up a interesting
question. Yes. Donald Trump continuously
say the only reason why he attacked was
so that Iran could not have a nuclear
weapon. Yes. Yes. But other people like
Ted Cruz advocate for a regime change.
Yes, they want a regime change because
then it will be easy to craft. If they
all get into the same wagon, then they
can all become part of this uh Abrahamic
accord. Now, interestingly, Martin, the
religion of Iran used to be
Zorastianism. Mhm. Okay. Now in the time
of Daniel,
the Persians had of course their pagan
religion and Daniel introduced the idea
of this Messiah that was going to come,
right?
And this was taken up later and a
mixture of the ancient uh Persian
religion and thoughts from the book of
Daniel or from Daniel's prophecy because
he was a very influential person were
mingled in there and this savior that
was to come was part of it and this was
Zoroastism.
Zoroastism actually gave rise to forms
of Hinduism and later out of that
Buddhism. So many of the the the
thinking patterns
that you have in the eastern religions
today
had this issue of a sa savior Vishnu the
one who had the holes in his feet and
the the holes in his hands. And the idea
was, you know, was that before or was
that after the biblical time period? The
idea is that Daniel actually influenced
that thinking via Zoroastism.
But with the Muslim revolution, Zoraism
was overthrown basically and the Muslim
religion uh took its place.
Then the question was who was going to
be the leader and it basically was an
internal struggle. Now of course the
Arabians they believe that with Mecca
they are the custodians and the other
ones believe no they have the bloodline.
So the originally the Muslim world when
they took over was sort of Shia
orientated and Sunni orientated
but Iran actually over time threw out
the Sunni Muslims and they escaped from
Iran and fled to Turkey for example or
any of the other Arabic states. And so
today over 90% of what is left in Iran
is Shia. Okay. Now if Shia and Sunni can
politically reconcile
which is a very difficult thing yeah
because there's the there's religion in
Yes. And if they can be brought into the
Abrahamic Accord, that would be quite a
milestone. Worthy of a Nobel Prize for
Donald Trump, don't you think? For sure.
All right, Martin.
What do they have in common?
They don't trace their ancestry to
Jesus. No. Because that creates a divide
between religions, right? The one says
Jesus is the kingpin. The other one
says, "No, Muhammad is the kingpin."
So the Christians won't accept Muhammad
and Muhammadans won't accept Jesus
Christ as the founder. The only way to
resolve the issue is let's go back
further in history and let's make it
Abraham. Abraham. Yeah. Then we can say,
well, the Jews come from Abraham via
Isaac. Mhm. And Jacob. And Islam says,
"No, we come from Abraham via Ishmael."
And the Christians follow the line that
the Jews followed and say, "All right,
that led to Jesus Christ." So, we'll
call it the Abrahamic Accord.
Uh, Martin, do you realize that the
Abrahamic Accord therefore excludes
Jesus Christ? Of course. Yeah. because
you there's um with the Jews and with
the with Islam he's excluded completely.
Ahu but there's a a three grouping over
there. Islam, Judaism and Catholic
Christianity if I can say so. Now
Martin,
who will be the primary kingpin in that
alliance? The pope.
The pope. Yeah. Haven't all the leaders
made accords with the pope? Haven't they
signed documents of fraternity? Yeah.
With the pope? Mhm. So he is sort of a a
member of equals
but slightly more equal than the others.
All right. Doesn't that mean that they
have to have an accord where they accept
this situation? Yeah. Now Roman
Catholicism does it believe in the
atonement? No. No. It denies the
atonement. It denies that you are saved
by the blood of the lamb. You are saved
through the works
of Christ and the saints. You are not
saved by the blood of the lamb. He died
as an example of perfect obedience, but
not for you. That is why you must all
pay for your own sins in purgatory.
We've said this a thousands of times.
And the whole doctrine of purgatory and
the treasury of merit is a concocted
doctrine that you find nowhere in the
scriptures. But that is Catholic
theology. It is a denial of the
atonement. Yeah. Right. Good. So they
deny the atonement. Does Islam deny the
atonement? No, for sure. Definitely.
They call it a false doctrine. They call
it an anathema.
Does the Jewish religion deny that Jesus
is the one that died for your sins? Yes.
Completely. So the three religions in
the Abrahamic accord all deny the
atonement.
Therefore they deny the gospel. Yeah.
Therefore it is a
uh accord of antichrist. Yes. Because it
denies the atonement of Christ. It is an
antichrist accord. I don't know whether
Donald Trump is aware of that that he
wants a Nobel Peace Prize for a antirist
accord.
I wonder if he knows. I don't know
whether he knows that. But that is the
issue. If you can unite them
there together under this triune union.
In other words, you break the power of
the Shi and force them to become part of
the bigger group and then to be part of
the Abrahamic accord with the chairman
of the board being the papacy.
Then you are paying homage to the
papacy. Yeah, right. That's it. Okay.
Now, Martin, this is very interesting.
So, is this a reality that is going on
there? It's irrelevant whether it's a
real war, whether it's a fake war,
whether it is
actual uh retribution for uh atomic
activity or whether it is not. It's
irrelevant. The question is what will
the outcome be? Yeah. Where is it
heading? And does it affect the issue of
what the king of the north, the papacy,
is doing and the beast out of the earth,
Protestant America, what they are doing.
Is America involved in all of this? Yes,
definitely. Doesn't the Bible say that
it will enforce the mark of the beast?
Yes, it will do the bidding on behalf of
the first beast. Now, wouldn't an
Abrahamic accord help the papacy to make
sure that whatever they decree becomes
universal as long as it's not linked
directly to Christ? For sure. I mean, it
will open the pathway also for the
legislation of the the mark of the
beast. Okay. So, let's just finish
reading what it says over there because
it says that the accords, a series of
agreements signed between several Arab
League nations and Israel that were
negotiated by the US at this point in
time. Does it exclude Iran? Yes.
Uh, no. You mean on what? Yeah. Yes.
It's Iran is not part of this yet.
Wouldn't it been nice if it were part of
it? Of course, we have to get them on
board. Is this a war
about the Jews and Israel or is it a war
to get them on board? That's why, like I
said earlier, most of these other people
say it must be a regime change to get
probably them on board on this. They
want peace. The only way to get peace is
to get them part of the accord. Okay.
So the Arab League nations and Israel
signed this accord negotiated by the US.
It must have been with the permission of
the papacy because it's part of it.
the Islamic nations.
Now there's one that's still
outstanding.
So this was in 2020 aimed to normalize
relations between them to deescalate
tensions in the Middle East.
Uh there were even rumors a few years
ago that Saudi Arabia and Iran would
actually go into a war,
but that didn't happen. So you know,
isn't it nice that the United States is
helping now and Israel is helping there?
Yeah. Because after all of this,
everything is quiet now. Yes. And why?
He said it will be and everybody was
screaming World War II started. Yes. But
this shows you that there's something
going on here. There's something strange
going on here. So modern even if they
set up their Ottoman type empire again
and Turkey plays an important role it'll
only bring that accord into a situation
of reality. That's all that's all that
will happen. So let's go a little step
further and just talk about some of
these issues.
Here's a very interesting one where we
go back to what's actually happening in
the United States and let's take our
focus away from the Middle East.
Why critics believe that Trump's big win
in the Supreme Court is terrifying step
towards authoritarianism.
Martin
in the biblical picture that Revelation
chapter 13 paints
this entity, this beast, this political
power which is a Christian political
power
which has clout to dictate to the whole
world must dictate Christian morality.
Right. Yeah.
That is a problem in terms of the
constitution.
Yes. And the secular world is opposed to
it.
Now it is our opinion
that the king of the south is not Islam
because he can't be the king of the
north and the king of the south or
something in between at the same time.
But that the king of the south is the
Egyptian mindset of who is the lord that
I should obey his voice. Yes. Pharaoh's
mindset that correct and communism and
it's secularism. It is getting rid of
God out of every walk of life. That is
the king of the south philosophy that
the king of the north, the Catholic
Church with its partners as we shall see
will try to overthrow.
So the war that the Bible talks about
north and south is the Christian mindset
as opposed to the secular mindset.
That's what it is about. Now this fear
that uh the power of the paper of that
the power of the presidency will become
so great that he can legislate over and
above the constitution
is becoming a reality. So let's read
what the critics are actually saying
over there. By a majority of six to
three, the highest court in the land has
ruled that federal judges have been
overreaching in their authority by
blocking or freezing the executive
orders issued by the president.
So is the Supreme Court giving him more
power?
Much more. Over the last few months, a
series of presidential actions by Trump
have been blocked by injunctions issued
by federal district judges. So these
federal judges branded radical radical
leftist lunatics. King of the South
philosophy
by the president have ruled on numerous
individual cases, most involving
immigration. Doesn't matter what it
involves. The question is, is he going
to get this power?
They've been applied their ruling as
nationwide injunctions, thus blocking
the Trump administration's policy.
That's not only immigration. It has to
do with anti-Israel
movements and uh you know anti-Jewish
activities. He's fighting against the
universities that have this secular
mindset. He's fighting against the woke
policies. He's fighting against uh
transgenderism
in sport. There's a whole plethora of
issues of a secular nature. Actually,
king of the south nature. Yes. King of
the south nature that he's overrunning.
He came with all of this just as the
Bible said and he just it pushed. Didn't
it push in the last four years against
this? Absolutely. He now before Trump it
was the king of the south this
secularism.
That was getting rid of the religious
power. It was it was pushing against the
king of the north. Taking the king of
the north power away. And now with
Trump, he's pushing back and he's
obliterating this mindset. And he is
using the economy to do it. And the
Bible said that he will use the ships.
Yeah. The ships of Kim. That's the
economy. So Harvard University, if you
don't play ball and stop fighting
against religious concepts that we hold
dear, like Ted Cruz said, we will take
away billions of your funding. Yeah. And
you can scramble. And I see now, Martin,
that one university after the other is
capitulating. Yeah. In Los Angeles, he's
sent in the military. So he uses
military as well to get military as
well. And and he said that he would do
it. So he's obliterating that mindset
and while he is doing it in America he
is setting an example for Europe
and have been saying it with so many
words. So the war is to get rid of
secularism
so that the king of the north can set up
his kingdom again here on earth of a
religious nature. They've got a done
deal in the Middle East. They are
already religious entities ruling. Yeah.
It's the Christian world that now needs
a similar construct. If we just look at
when he went to NATO, yes, recently they
were in awe. They even called him daddy.
They called him daddy. So he's using his
military power. He's using his
uh religious power. He's set up
organizations
within the White House to propagate
religious agendas. And in order to do
this, he has to overrun the king of the
south, secularism's mindset.
This is what he's doing. And the Supreme
Court,
what is the major religion that is
represented there? Catholic. Catholic.
What is it doing? It is giving him
power. power Martin. This is where
prophecy is to be unfolded. This is
where our attention is to be. So in
simple terms, it says this ruling from a
Supreme Court weighted towards
conservative judges. Let's rephrase
that. Catholic judges. Conservative
Catholic judges. That will be more
towards prevatican 2. Correct. frees up
the president to push on with his agenda
less opposed by the courts.
This is such a big day. The president
said it gives power back to the people.
No, it gives power back to the papacy
that should have it. Including Congress,
including the presidency and it only
takes bad power away from the judges. It
takes bad power, sick power, unfair
power. Can you see the adjectives he's
using?
Is there a war against secularism? Very,
very clearly. And are they trying to set
up a kingdom? Definitely. Are they
dominionists? Oh, yes. Are they
millennialists?
Yes. Now, we'll come to that in a
moment. Very important. We'll come to
that in a moment because this is so
important
and uh we have to look at the kingdom of
God, right? Yeah. In order to understand
this because of your mindset is that
there will be a kingdom on earth before
Jesus comes. Yes. Then you're going to
be caught up in all of this. You're
going to be caught up in this. So let's
just make it quite clear. Whatever
happens over there is an attempt to
bring about a religious unity with the
papacy as the chairperson.
It's called the Abrahamic Accord.
Sunni and Shi have to all be on board.
What if you give some mindsets the idea
that they are terrorists? M you can
actually switch from Saudi Arabia 9/11
to Iran if you want to and whoever is
not playing ball is the target of the
day. Look at the switch now they in
Saudi Arabia received Trump with pump
and and wasn't there a great economic
accord between them? What's it53
trillion dollar? uh there was a massive
accord right and in the meantime while
all this is taking place it doesn't only
affect the Middle East because it
affects the oil pipeline so it affects
China and China is feeling the squeeze
and Russia is feeling the squeeze on the
other side with Ukraine issue Martin
they're all going to come aboard and
they're going to shout peace peace peace
and safety the peace will unravel at
some stage age and there will be chaos.
We know that from the scriptures, but
there will be a but for the moment what
they're working for is peace.
Now, let's look at the kingdom of God.
If we go to John 18:36
Jesus said, "My kingdom is not of this
world." Mhm. That's a very basic
statement. It is the foundation that
this whole argument should be built on.
Yeah. Wouldn't you agree with that? I
agree 100%. This is what it is all
about. This is the foundation. My
kingdom is not of this world. If my
kingdom were of this world,
then would my servants fight
that I should not be delivered to the
Jews. But now is my kingdom not from
hands. Okay. So, his kingdom is not from
this world. It's another kind of
kingdom.
Now, did the Jews try to set up a
kingdom? Yes.
They're upset that they didn't get the
kingdom. Very, very upset. Did they have
a mindset that the kingdom must be set
up down here? They definitely did. These
disciples as well. Who was going to rule
in that kingdom? Well, if it was the
plan of Jesus, then he would have been
king and they would have ruled with him
on earth. So, they would have all been
the kingpins in his cabinet. But then he
would have to chase out the Romans and
set up an earthly kingdom and chastise
anyone that didn't agree with him.
Right? So to prove that that wasn't the
thing he's not there. He's in heaven.
Okay? And now the church wants to be
there. Now he didn't want to set up that
kind of kingdom. So what did they do
with him? Killed him. Got rid of him.
They got rid of him. All right. So his
kingdom is not of this world. And if it
were, his his servants would fight. One
of his own disciples was a zealot. Yeah.
Wanting to set up this kingdom. And he
he said, "No, it's not going to be like
this."
Now, in Luke 16:E1 16, we read, "The law
and the prophets." That's the Bible
without the New Testament.
Right?
The law and the prophets were until
John.
That's John the Baptist.
So the law and the prophets, the Bible
and what it entailed and what it taught
as such was active until John the
Baptist.
Since that time,
the kingdom of God is preached. In other
words, the Messiah
that was written about in the Torah and
by all the prophets had come to this
earth and now his kingdom was preached.
Was it set up? No. It was preached. Yes.
And every man pressth into it. Yes. You
can get into it or you could decide to
stay out of it. Right. Okay. Martin, now
let's just get this straight.
So whatever was written in the
scriptures in the in the Torah, the
first five books of Moses and what all
the prophets testified
that was of absolute relevance until the
time of John. Mhm. Then something must
have changed. The Messiah came. Yeah.
But he didn't come according to their
concept. He said that the kingdom has
come near. Aha. Not has come. No. So
they they couldn't deal with him. So it
was better that he die than that their
idea of the kingdom should go. It's
better it's better that one man die.
Yeah. For the sake of the kingdom that
the whole kingdom should be destroyed
because of one man. So get rid of him.
So since the time of John the Baptist
who was the herald of Jesus and said
behold the lamb of God that taketh away
the sins of the world. There he is.
That's him.
Since that time the kingdom of God is
preached and people are pressing into
it. Yeah. So, so according to this
Martin since when does this kingdom
exist here on earth? Since Jesus. Since
the time of Jesus. Since the time of
John the Baptist. Is it a physical
kingdom where you have soldiers and
political entities enforcing your will?
No. No. It's a spiritual kingdom. It's a
spiritual because he says otherwise they
my servants would fight. But they're not
fighting. No. He said, "Put your sword
away. What you're doing? Why you
chopping off this ear? Why do you want
to force the issue?" Right? It's a it's
a kingdom of choice. Aha. That's very
important. It's a kingdom of choice.
This is a that's why how you press into
it. You must must make a cognitive
decision that I want to be part of this.
So you can only be part of it by faith,
not forced. You cannot go to a country
to be part of it. So nobody can force
you. Yeah. Yeah. That's very
interesting. I can't go to the United
States and say, "Okay, I see you're
setting up the kingdom. I'm going to be
living here right now." No, you can't do
that. It's a spiritual kingdom. And even
if worldly worldwide, God's laws are
enforced. Correct. That's still not
getting you into his kingdom. Now, this
is in Luke 16. Did the disciples
understand this? No. Did the Jews
understand it? No. Not at all. No. Now,
let's go till after the resurrection.
Let's go to the ascension, right? This
is the heading in the King James. The
heading in the King James Bible says the
ascension.
It's in Acts chapter one. So when they
therefore were come together, they asked
of him. This is after the resurrection.
In fact, this is where Jesus is going to
go to heaven permanently. That's 40
days. Mhm. After his resurrection.
They asked him there saying, "Lord,
wil thou at this time restore again the
kingdom of Israel?" So he still didn't
understand. Still not because previously
it said the kingdom is here and people
are pressing in. But they're still
waiting for it. They didn't see it.
Not they still don't see it to this very
day. You we heard it earlier. Okay,
let's let's continue. And he said unto
them, "It's not for you to know the
times and the seasons which the Father
has put in his own power, but you shall
receive power after the Holy Ghost is
come upon you, and you shall be
witnesses unto me, both in Jerusalem and
in all Judea and in Samaria and unto the
uttermost part of the earth." That's
your job. Preach the gospel. Stop
worrying about when the kingdom will be
set up.
Right. Yeah. So, he wasn't going to set
it up. No. Just do your work. Yeah.
Preach the gospel. Preach the gospel.
Not set up my kingdom. No. No. My
kingdom is not of this world. Please
stop it. That's what he said, right?
Okay.
Now, let's go to Daniel. You remember
the statue. Of course, we have the head
of gold. We have the the arms of silver
which represent the Meo Persian Empire.
You had the bronze of the Greek Empire
and then you had the legs of iron and
there were two legs because there was an
eastern and a western Roman Empire. And
then you had the feet of iron and clay
and the 10 toes which represent the
powers that would come out of this
entity out of Rome, the divided powers
of Europe. And Daniel says in chapter
2:43, "And whereas thou sourest iron
mixed with miry clay, they shall mingle
themselves with the seed of men, but
they shall not cleave one to another,
even as iron is not mixed with clay." So
this divided kingdom which will consist
of iron and clay, churchcraft and state
craft, the iron being statecraft,
they will not mingle.
and constant turmoil between them. And
they tried with the literal mingling of
the kings tried to reunite the iron and
the priests tried to unite the iron with
the clay. It just didn't work. And in
the days of these kings,
shall the God of heaven set up a
kingdom? So, who's going to set up the
kingdom? God. Oh, I thought the priests
are going to set it up and the pastors
are going to set it up and the political
entities are going to set it up. Is that
going to happen? No. No. The God of
heaven is going to set up a kingdom. And
that kingdom will never be destroyed.
And the kingdom shall not be left to
other people. So, Donald Trump is not
going to run it. Is the church going to
run it? No. It says there it's not going
to be left to other people. I'm reading
scripture now.
But it
shall break in pieces and consume all
these kingdoms and it shall stand
forever. So whether we're talking about
literal Israel or whether we're talking
about Rome or whether we're talking
about the United States, they will not
rule this kingdom. No.
Then what's Ted Cruz saying? Isn't he
confused? Yes. And what about the other
role players? Unfortunately, everybody
that is expecting a kingdom
set up before God sets it up, forget it.
He's not going to play a part. It It
says so. So then it describes it. For as
much as thou sawst that the stone, this
rock
which was cut out of the mountain
without hands, nobody helped him. God is
setting up the kingdom. Christ is the
rock and the stone and it break in
pieces the iron,
the political systems of Rome, brass,
Greek philosophy,
clay,
the religious systems on the earth, and
that it break in pieces all of this
stuff, the silver and the gold. That's
Babylon.
The great God has made known to the king
what shall come to pass hereafter, and
the dream is certain. And the
interpretation thereof is sure. So
Martin, are any of these powers going to
set up a religious system that is the
kingdom? No. They're probably going to
try. Did Babylon try? Yes. Did Persia
try? For sure. Did Greece try? Oh,
definitely. Did Rome try? Did Paper Rome
try? Is the Protestant world going to
try? They're still trying. They're
trying. Everybody's trying. Let's jump
to Revelation chapter 17.
Now, Robert and Marlo,
they did one called Beauty and the Beast
exploring Revelation chapter 17. I think
people can really go and they can go and
look at that. They shouldn't only watch
what's they should watch his truth also.
Definitely. And this was together with
other ministry as well with Steve
Wahberg who happened to be a Jew before
he became a Christian. Right. So, there
are some very good insights in that.
Don't look at that. And Martin, this
woman that rides the beast,
she is called the mother of harlots. Now
the Protestant world, which seems to
have forgotten this, used to believe and
taught that this was the papacy. Yeah.
This church, this woman that had what on
her forehead? And upon her forhead was
written a name mystery,
Babylon the great,
the mother of harlots,
and abominations of the earth. Now, the
abominations of the earth, we've done a
whole series on that. Idolatry.
Idolatry. Okay.
Modern. Any system of salvation that
excludes Jesus Christ as the atoning
sacrifice is idolatry. Right. That's it.
So the Abrahamic Accord is what?
Idolatry. It's idolatry. It's an it's an
abomination. Yeah. Because it excludes
the Messiah, right? It takes it back to
Abraham with a very point of excluding
him in order to get an accord. That's a
to get and that's the only way
ecommenism works. It's the same. You
have to get rid of Jesus otherwise there
cannot be any ecumenism.
Now mother she is the mother of harlots
right and she's a church.
So the mother has daughters.
Anybody who signs an accord with her in
an ecumenical council
is a harlot. M any church that signs an
ecumenical accord with this woman is a
harlot. Right. Yeah. Is that a very
harsh word? It's biblical. Okay. Now,
some denominations might have
individuals that have signed it but
haven't signed it as a church. Very. So,
they have harlots within them but
they're not the harlot. Exactly. Let's
make that very plain. Mhm. But if a
church as a body has signed, then they
become a harlot. Yeah. Is that what it
says? Yes. Now, what's on her name? It's
called what? Mystery. Babylon the great.
Babylon.
Confusion. Now, Martin, Babylon, wasn't
that the king of the north? Yes.
Now, I'm confused, Martin. M if Babylon
was the king of the north
and if you don't believe that Babylon
was the king of the north then please go
and read the book of Jeremiah
who states that Babylon is coming from
the north and he's going to attack
Jerusalem
then Babylon must be this harlot woman
because that's written on her forehead
Babylon. So who's the king of the north?
Babylon. It's still the same the papacy.
It's okay. Roman. Can it be Islam? No.
Islam is with her in an accord called
the Abrahamic Accord. It's it's the
Protestant churches are with her in an
accord called what? Echimemenism. Is it?
Who's the mother? Still the same thing.
Babylon still. And she's Babylon. Then
she must be the king of the north. So
all this nonsense that Turkey is the
king of the north is nothing short but
nonsense because it says there that she
is Babylon. Yeah. And Babylon is the
king of the north.
That's it. Is this the point or not? I
think so. Okay. So let's just go a
little bit further into this kingdom.
Luke 17 20. And when he was demanded of
the Pharisees when the kingdom of God
should come,
they wanted to know too.
Now answered them and said, "The kingdom
of God cometh not with observation."
See, in other words, you can't see it in
unfolding on the news. I It's so clear
this the how the Bible states it. The
kingdom of God cometh not with
observation, Martin. So can I observe
what's happening here with rumors and
the reality in the Middle East as to the
kingdom being set up? It's going to take
your attention and you're going to miss
something important.
The kingdom does not come with
observation.
You can't read about it in the newspaper
that it's been set up. You can't look at
it with binoculars from the golden
heights.
It doesn't come with observation.
Neither shall they say low here or low
there. For behold, the kingdom of God is
within you. It's a decision that you
have to make.
It's very clear.
What? I'm not being mean now, am I?
I don't think we can be mean. We just
want people to realize this. Please,
please just get your focus right.
And he said unto his disciples,
"The day will come when you shall desire
to see one of the days of the Son of
Man, and you shall not see it. And they
shall say to you, see here, or see
there." Go not after them. Don't follow
them. Don't run into this kingdom
nonsense.
The kingdom is going to be set up by
God. Yeah. Right now, you're pressing
in.
I've pressed in because I want Jesus as
my my savior. I accept the atonement of
Jesus Christ. Uh you know, all of those
issues. I'm trying to press in. Aren't
you pressing in? I'm trying my best
because as lightning that lightens out
of the one part unto heaven shine unto
the other part unto heaven. So also the
son of man be in his day. When Christ
comes, that's when he sets up the
kingdom. Yes. And then you will be able
to observe it. But until then,
don't go there. Don't go there.
It won't be set up before he comes. All
right. So, what was the kingdom like
then? Let's read. Luke 10:9.
Heal the sick that are therein, and say
unto them, the kingdom of God is come
nigh unto you. It's not there yet, but
it's so close. Accept it by faith.
Matthew 24:14.
And this gospel of the kingdom shall be
preached in all the world for a witness
unto all nations and then shall the end
come. But it doesn't say there then the
kingdom is set up then the end shall
come. Then the end will come. There's a
difference because these people believe
that they will be preaching the gospel
and then basically you can in hard terms
say enforce the kingdom on all because
they want to put in legislation. You
can't do that. So should we continue
preaching to the Jews to accept Jesus as
the Messiah? Yes. Should we continue
preaching to the Islamic world that they
must accept Jesus as the Messiah?
Absolutely.
Now, Martin, the Islamic world used to
believe,
and many of them still do, that they're
going to introduce Sharia law in the
entire world, overrun the entire world,
get rid of all other religions so that
only they rule. Have they been very
disappointed of late in terms of
achieving that victory? Definitely. So
aren't they a little bit disillusioned
with their world view by now? They are.
And then you've got the other side that
think that they are going to try and
push this. So they must stop this. All
right. So now then you have the
Christian side that might believe all
right you have to convert every one of
them. Uh they will also be disillusioned
because it is a personal choice. It's a
personal choice. Okay. So Luke 21 of
course is the parallel text to Matthew
24 and it says, "So likewise ye, when
you see these things come to pass, these
end time events, know ye that the
kingdom of God is nigh at hand and will
be set up by Donald Trump or by his
administration or whatever." Does it say
that? No.
Matthew 25:34,
"Then shall the king say unto them on
his right hand," "Come ye blessed of my
father, inherit the kingdom prepared for
you from the foundation of the world."
What? What does that tell you? It's not
of this earth. It's been prepared. And
who's doing it? He's doing it. And he's
going to
separate the wheat from the chaff. Yeah.
and he will decide who will be part of
his kingdom because in this other one no
politician no that's exactly the view
that the Christian world must set up
this kingdom on behalf of Christ
directly negates what you just said
because then there's no free will choice
there's no choice so the Jews thought
they would rule and the disciples even
thought they would sit on the left and
on the right and they would be rulers,
right? That that's so great.
And uh those that believe in the
millennium
will say, "Well, you know, we'll rule.
You know, Jesus, I'm we're very happy
that you're there, but we've got this.
We've got this under control. Everybody
will be forced to listen to what you
have to say."
and one after the other is beginning to
say in the evangelical world we will
have to enforce this morality.
I want to encourage people to go and
look at the latest one that Little Light
Studio brought out on the implementation
of the Sunday law and this mindset of
taking control. They did an excellent
job. Go and look at Little Light
Studios. Perhaps you can put a link in.
I'll put the link and then also on the
screen there'll probably be a
advertisement of it. Yes, they are spot
on with that particular one and we don't
have to repeat it. They've done a very
good job. We've said many of those
things, similar ones in the past, but
this brings it up to speed as to where
we are today. Great job, uh, Little
Light Studios. So,
this is what will happen and how this
kingdom will be set up. Let's go a
little bit further. Luke chapter 10.
Heal the sick.
This is what Jesus tells his disciples
to go and do. Heal the sick. Not go and
set up a kingdom. Heal the sick that are
therein. Say unto them, the kingdom of
God is come nigh unto you.
Even the very dust of your city which
cleaveth unto us. If they don't accept
this, you go and preach the gospel.
Even this dust we do wipe off against
you. Notwithstanding, be ye sure of
this, that the kingdom of God is come
nigh unto you. You had an opportunity
now. You heard the gospel. You don't
want to accept it. We wipe the dust off
our feet. We're not going to force you.
But remember, it's come nigh unto you.
Yeah. So, this message has come to you.
What you going to do with it is your
choice. That's your choice. And as they
heard these things, he added and spake a
parable because he was nigh to Jerusalem
because they thought that the kingdom of
God should immediately appear. Did they
have a right concept? No. No, no, no. It
was a literal one, a visible one of
correct. So likewise ye, when you see
these things come to pass, know ye that
the kingdom of God is nigh at hand.
All right. Now Matthew 13
verse 37 and onwards he answered and
said unto them he that seweth the good
seed is the son of man. This is how the
kingdom is going to be set up right the
field is the world.
The whole world
the good seed are the children of the
kingdom
by choice. by choice. They heard the
gospel. The seed that has been sown is
the word of God. Right? So the field is
the world. Not just the United States or
Europe.
It's the world. The good seeds are the
children of the kingdom. But the tears
are the children of the wicked one.
The enemy that swed them is the devil.
The harvest is the end of the world and
the reapers are the angels. We're not
going to reap on God's behalf. Tears
will be there. Yes. Until the end. Till
the end. As therefore the tears are
gathered and burnt in the fire, so shall
it be in the end of the world.
Right?
The Son of Man shall send forth his
angels,
and they shall gather out of his kingdom
all things that offend, and them which
do iniquity.
So even those that claim to be Christian
nations
will have tears and good seed. And who
decides what happens to that? God does.
I thought they're going to force the bad
seed to become good seed. Well, this is
this good luck. This is the same that we
the one that we did last time about the
church, about the remnant. Shut up, the
liberal judges. Yes, go ahead. Do
whatever you can. You're not going to
change the mind. No, but you're not also
in inside of the church, inside of God's
remnant. We don't te pluck out the
tears. God is doing this. So, what's he
going to do with the tears? He will cast
them into a furnace of fire and there
shall be wailing and nashing of teeth.
Then shall the righteous sign forth as
the son in the kingdom of their father
but the one that he said who has ears
let him hear. So there will be no
setting up of an earthly kingdom. It is
fool's paradise. So let's ask a question
here.
Do we set up an earthly kingdom while
the bridegroom carries? Well, that's
what most believers should do. Yeah,
obviously he's ting. So let's fix this
thing for him. We got this. No, we
don't. We don't have at all. Blessed is
he who is not offended because the
Messiah's mission because of the
Messiah's mission just because it is not
what they think it should be.
Right? So, let's look at this. Luke
7:19.
And John, this is now John the Baptist,
calling unto him two of his disciples,
sent them to Jesus,
saying, "Art thou he that should come,
or look for another?" The poor man is
sitting in jail.
He's got the sword of Damocles over his
head
and he's wondering now if Jesus is going
to set up the kingdom, why doesn't he
obliterate all this opposition and set
him free? Right? Yes. He's expecting a
kingdom to come and it's not happening
and he's he's disappointed
as were his disciples. Right? Even after
his death, they were still asking him,
"Are you going to set up the kingdom
now?"
So let's look at this. Art thou he that
should come? He's the one, Martin, that
saw the dove descend.
He's the one that got the sign. Him on
whom you see it happening. He's the one.
He heard the voice. He heard the voice.
He said, "Behold the lamb of God." He's
in even disarray. Yeah. because things
are not happening like he thought they
should happen.
So when the men were come unto him, they
said to Jesus, "Now, John the Baptist
has sent us unto thee, saying, "Art thou
he that should come, or look before
another?"
Why you not doing what you're supposed
to do? Keep on preparing the way instead
of What's going on here?
Huh? wait for another. And in that same
hour, he didn't even answer them.
He didn't give them an answer. In that
same hour, he cured many of their
infirmities
and plagues and evil spirits. And unto
many that were blind, he gave sight.
Then Jesus answering said unto them, "Go
your way and tell John what things you
have seen and heard." Well, so he didn't
tell them, he showed them. He showed
them how that the blind see, the lame
walk, the lepers are cleansed, the deaf
hear, the dead are raised,
to the poor the gospel is preached. The
gospel of the kingdom, right? Yeah. And
blessed is he who ever shall not be
offended in me.
All right, let's spirit put this in a
spiritual one.
Tell him what you saw and what you
heard. The spiritually blind Mhm. are
beginning to understand.
Those that have been made lame by false
doctrines are beginning to walk. Those
that are full of the leprosy of sin are
being cured of their sins by confessing
them
and accepting the atonement of Christ so
that they can be cleansed. That that
never understood the gospel are now
hearing what it's all about. And those
that are spiritually dead are being
raised. And those that are spiritually
poor in understanding become rich.
Right. Yeah. That's the spiritual
aspect.
And John the Baptist is sitting there
and he's saying, "Well, if this is what
the disciples that I sent to Jesus saw,
what was the mission of the Messiah?"
And he remembers, remember all that he
had was the Old Testament. He remembers
Isaiah.
Ah, Isaiah chapter 61. The spirit of the
Lord God is upon me because the Lord has
anointed me to preach good tidings unto
the meek. He has sent me to bind up the
brokenhearted, to proclaim liberty to
the captives and the opening of the
prison to them that are bound, to
proclaim the acceptable year of the Lord
and the day of vengeance of our God. to
comfort all that mourn, to appoint unto
them that mourn in Zion, to give them
beauty for ashes, oil for the joy of
mourning, a garment of praise for the
spirit of heaviness, that they might be
called trees of righteousness, the
planting of the Lord, that he might be
glorified. Is this an earthly kingdom or
a spiritual kingdom? It's so beautiful.
It's a spir spiritual kingdom, Martin,
why does everybody want this earthly
kingdom? I think it has to do with
self-righteousness and self again. So
Martin, let's sum this up.
Ever since time
immemorial,
everybody wanted to be the ruler of the
kingdom. Yeah.
And eventually the Jews thought they
were going to be the ones and they were
waiting for the Messiah to fulfill it.
The Messiah comes, he's not doing what
they want. They kill him. His own
disciples
think, "Okay, that was a mistake. He's
going to do it still." He doesn't do it.
John the Baptist loses heart. And says,
"Why is it not happening? I have a wrong
concept."
And he is preaching a spiritual kingdom.
and he will set up a kingdom that will
never be destroyed.
But before he sets it up, he first has
to get rid of everything that there is.
So modern, if the Christian church now
sets up this kingdom for a thousand
years
according to that text, is Jesus then
coming to destroy it? Yes. It's
pathetic, isn't it? It's a it's it's sad
because they're still doing the same.
They also will be probably killing
putting people to death that doesn't
want to conform to what their thinking
is of correct. So we have a repetition
of this over and over again. But the
good news is
I believe we are really at the end of
time
because the Christian world that accepts
the Messiah
is pushing away secularism
and is wanting to set up that kingdom
and will enforce the laws of the king of
the north. Yeah. Which includes the mark
of the beast. They are setting up an
Abrahamic accord in the Middle East and
everybody has to be on board for that
because Catholicism
believes in a millennialism.
They believe that they will rule
forever. They don't believe in a
millennium where the Jews will rule or
where you know some other entity will
rule. they will rule. They don't believe
in the millennium. And the ideas
like we have seen
that the Christian world adheres to
either the secret rapture and
dispensationalism
where the Jews set up the kingdom down
here for a thousand years or the
Christian idea of Christian nationalism
where the Christians set up their
kingdom. Mhm. That is a Jesuit
construct. Yeah. The Catholics don't
care about that because they're a
millennialist. They in any case going to
rule forever, but they want to rule.
Now, the Protestants also want to rule.
So, give them a false doctrine. They
will rule. Okay? And some believe they
will be in heaven and some believe that
they will rule down here. It doesn't
matter to Rome. No. as long as Rome
rules and she is the chairman of the
board.
That is where the rubber meets the road
and not with what Turkey does or what
Iran does or what a literal Israel where
that is a Masonic construct does. The
kingdom is going to be set up once God's
people are being
legislated against. Yeah. And the king
of the north's philosophy becomes the
law of the land. I hope people will will
really take note, re-watch and look out
for that discussion that we have on the
17th of July. That's the issue. You will
see. You will see. Let's pray. Amen.
Heavenly Father, please Lord, wipe away
the confusion out there. You have given
us clear directives as to what our
mission is. It is spelt out for us in
Revelation chapter 14. We have to warn
against the mark of the beast. We must
not become part of Babylon. We must
preach the everlasting gospel. That is
our duty. Those are our marching orders.
Let us not become confused with what's
happening in local issues here and
there.
help us to focus on the message for our
time is my prayer in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
[Music]